welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos in the Star Wars universe will now
have marble head Kevin Feige developing
a future film making even denser the
already packed Star Wars timeline with
upcoming properties like the Mandalorian
Series on Disney plus plus episode 9 the
rise of Skywalker plus a noun series for
obi-wan Kenobi Kassian and/or other
projects and development I feel like we
are in desperate need of an update to
the Star Wars canonical chronology and
we got it explained
so I'm gonna stick to the big events
that are relevant to these new
properties so I may not catalogue every
canonical Burt from ahsoka tano though
I'm sure her burps are awesome okay the
Star Wars timeline doesn't go by years
the way we mark our years by revolutions
of the earth around the Sun with a
calendar that uses the birth of Christ
as your zero or for some of you I'm sure
a Mayan calendar where the world ended
70 years ago and of course all the Star
Wars history takes place a long time ago
so for simplicity sake were applying
earth years to arguably the biggest
event in the star wars history that we
care about the destruction of the first
Death Star in the Battle of Yavin so
we're gonna use that as our birth of
Christ here zero before 0 will be BBY
before Battle of Yavin and after 0 will
be ABY after Battle of Yavin ok so we
can rewind all the way back to the dawn
of this fictional universe according to
Star Wars lore it all started with a so
called wellspring of life a force planet
from which midi-chlorians originated
some time after this ancestral beings
invented hyperspace travel the Prime
Jedi established the Jedi Order in the
first Jedi Temple on two and a dark
faction of the Jedi broke off to
eventually form the Sith and it brings
us to the age of the Old Republic which
was formed with its capital on Coruscant
and the temple on Jed ha and rogue one
was built 5000 years before the Battle
of Yavin that great temple was built on
Yavin 4 and then a thousand year war
between the Jedi and the Mandalorians
the warriors of Mandalore began this war
would eventually ravage the surface of
Mandalore forces people to live in these
domed cities but really destroy the
Mandalorians scattering them across the
galaxy and leading to one of them being
the star the Mandalorian coming up on
Disney Plus but that's thousands of
years later but then we come upon the
period of the Knights of the Old
Republic that is planned to be a trilogy
of movies based on the popular game and
at least the first movie of which will
be written by the game of thrones
showrunners Benioff and Weiss so jumping
ahead later about a thousand years
before the Battle of Yavin when the Old
Republic transitions to the Republic
governed by the Galactic Senate like the
Roman Republic and these days it seems
all democratic forms of government this
Senate collapsed under the weight of
corruption which brings us to the events
of episode 1 the Phantom Menace you know
the story here Anakin Skywalker is
discovered by the Jedi on Tatooine
there's an epic fight with Darth Maul
and the political drama between Naboo
and the Trade Federation since she
Palpatine to Supreme Chancellor the
Senate or as he was telling himself in
the mirror those days I am shedding so
10 years later were the events of Attack
of the Clones in which war breaks out
between the separatists of Count Dooku
and the Clone Trooper army of the
Republic which was actually a war
manufactured from both sides by
Palpatine and Darth Sidious smooth
around this time is when the events of
Star Wars the Clone Wars has set both
the movie and the series in which Anakin
and obi-wan are joined by ahsoka tano
the series is also known for
resurrecting Maul and shortly after this
construction of the Death Star begins on
Geonosis with plans for it seen in
attack of the clones two years later are
the events of Revenge of the Sith when
the Empire comes in to form Palpatine
reveals himself to Anakin corrupts him
into Darth Vader and gives old 66
killing most of the Jedi Luke and Leia
are born Padme dies and Yoda and obi-wan
go into exile and then eight years after
that will be of the events of the
upcoming obi-wan Kenobi series and we
don't know much about what it will be
about but obi-wan will be on Tatooine at
this time and since Maul is active the
two might have an awesome rematch now a
year after these events is a setting for
Solo a Star Wars story which introduced
Han Solo to Chewbacca and Lando
Calrissian in a story that brushed them
past small though they didn't know it
then five years after that start the
events of the animated series Star Wars
rebels following kanan jarrus and others
and their missions against the Empire
also during this era will be the events
of the casseon and/or series a prequel
series to rogue one
following the Diego Luna spy character
for that movie and that brings us to our
Year Zero starting with the events of
rogue one gen or so and casseon and/or
lead the mission to steal the Death Star
schematics from scare off' leading to a
battle and a very close call with darth
vader this narrative flows neatly into
the events of the very first Star Wars
film 1977 again we all know the story
here Luke Skywalker obi-wan Han Chewie
Alfre Leia and used the Death Star plans
to blow it up in the Battle of Yavin the
key turning point in the Galactic Civil
War so now we're in the after the Battle
of Yavin years ABY and three years after
this are the events of the Empire
Strikes Back the Battle of Hoth Luke's
training with Yoda on Dagobah and all
the drama in Cloud City with Lando and
Vader that freezes Han and Carbonite
another year passes until the events of
Return of the Jedi
Hans rescue in the Battle of Endor which
leads to the deaths of Palpatine
and Vader in the destruction of the
second Death Star and the beginning of
the end for the empire in the formation
of the New Republic but the Empire is
still not dead yet Palpatine has
posthumously ordered operations Cynder
ordering all remnants of the Imperial
Navy to basically burn everything down
this culminates in the battle of jakku
which marks the final defeat of the
empire some Imperial officers do a tip
escaping and they form the roots of what
is known as the first order now a few
years later will be the events of the
Mandalorian on Disney Plus following
Pedro Pascal's bounty hunter character
and the ruins of the empire and it
sounds like this series will shed some
light on the rise of the first order now
over the next few decades the New
Republic rules but the first order is
Rison led by Snoke Ben solo departs from
its training under Luke and joins the
first order as kylo Ren also the
animated series Star Wars resistance is
beginning during this time all this
leads to the events of the force awakens
in which the first order uses Starkiller
base to destroy hosnian prime and
several other planets but rey our new
hero unites with fin Han Chewie bb-8 and
the resistance led by leia and including
ace pilot poe dameron to destroy star
killer base and follow a star map to
long-lost Luke over on arch 2 and the
events of the last Jedi take place
immediately after this by the end of it
all
Luke and Snoke are dead add that to the
pile of bodies of Han from the force
awakens and the resistance is nearly
wiped out and then technically the
Disney attraction Star Wars Galaxies
edge is set after the Battle of crates
in the last Jedi with the Falcon now
parked at the black spire outpost on the
- in the outer rim and then one year
after the last Jedi will be the events
of the upcoming the rise of Skywalker
with kylo now running the first order
and it seems Rey encountering the ruins
of the second Death Star and somehow the
return of Palpatine beyond that we know
the last Jedi director Rian Johnson is
developing a trilogy of films that might
be set in a future beyond maybe
following that young stable boy on Kanto
bite and Kevin Feige Star Wars movie
could we sit at any point all we really
know at this point is that he has
approached one big-name actor to play a
certain character if the deal ever went
through so which character do you think
bagi Star Wars movie will follow donald
glover as Lando a live-action ahsoka
tano film comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at EI vas and subscribed to new
rock stars for breakdowns of everything
star wars thank you for joining me and
if Feige is working on an ahsoka tano
movie
feel like a burping contest needs to be
part of the casting process
[Music]